ce que vous arrivez à répondre aux
questions de questions pour un champion
j'ai répondu une fois omelette
hier c'était un truc de prime time
quand ça dure miller d'assurer et
pendant 1000 heures j'étais là
maintenant je sais pas si je sais pas et
je suis je suis une recette à base
d'oeuf jeunes et criaient
si c'est ça le truc que j'avais 10 ans
qui s'est fait relooker des trucs comme
ça alors mais ce n'est pas si vous avez
vu d'un voix de bronze qui la haye où il
arrive alors sur un trou en un clin
d'oeil
c'est incroyable il ya une voix le
conseil on l'appelle ma mère sur 200 m
il ya même un trophée qui a été créé de
la brosse les dents du jour alex toi tu
veux un truc aussi dans ton spectacle
parce que ça rejoint un petit peu ce
qu'a fait philippe tu parles des
chanteurs de télé crochet qui sont très
tristes
alors je suis l'aîné parce que ça fait
pas sympa non mais si c'est pas grave
non parce que quand ils sont trop c'est
drôle et des fois ils se rendent pas
compte de la signification de ce qu'il
chante
ouais c'est ça je crois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et a contrario sur tout à fait capable
de tata yoyo
oui est-ce que tu as le grand chapeau
[Rires]
j'ai eu un jour en tournée un mec qui
était habillé comme un inspecteur de
police si il m'a dit qu'il travaillait
chez chez vous ne pigez il m'a dit je
parie chez ferrero alors cette idée d'
affiches super bon salariat plus jamais
une nouvelle en plus et anti on n'y a
jamais eu de jamais eu de problème mais
c'est sympa mais si vous écrivez une bio
en tout cas cette anecdote mettez là
dedans
vous avez regardé pékin express ce soir
ont passé mais oui enfin je pense
il est là il est oui bien sûr